bonjour ici c'est steve kaufmann
je veux vous inviter à une discussion au
sujet de link
je veux un peu expliqué les nouvelles
fonctions que nous avons et je veux
entendre vos opinions
je vais vous montrer comment j'utilise
la page vous pouvez nous montrer ce que
vous faites si vous avez des suggestions
et des idéaux des choses que vous ne
trouvez pas bien ou que vous aimeriez
voir amélioré voilà c'est votre chance
votre occasion de me parler ou bien si
vous n'avez jamais utilisé linky ça vous
intéresse venez ça sera le samedi donc
le 1er décembre
ça sera aux heures blur du pacifique
s'est allié à vancouver mais selon le
cas si vous êtes à montréal ça sera donc
trois heures plus tard à deux heures de
l'après midi de samedi le 1er décembre
et si vous êtes en europe ça sera à 8
heures le soir le 1er décembre
donc peut-être que vous êtes vous allé
faire la fête que vous ne pourriez pas
venir mais pour ceux qui ont le temps
j'aimerais bien vous rencontrer et
parler un peu de link ça va se passer
sur google places
donc vous pouvez voir le lien ici en
dessous
demont vidéo à le lien à notre page
google places il faut venir et vous
annoncez soif le donnait en place un ou
des sides et de ne suivre et je dois
dire que je suis un peu confus avec tes
ces nouvelles technologies
c'est une espèce d'expérience que nous
faisons j'espère que ça va bien marcher
maintenant je ne prie pas ces
discussions en plusieurs langues
je fais des vidéos en plusieurs langues
je suis assez confus à ce moment là
c'est bon aussi mais j'espère vous voir
pour discuter en français le donc le 1er
décembre huit heures le soir en europe
aux heures du matin à vancouver et où
que vous soyez j'espère que j'ai pas
oublier que j'ai pas oublier de dire des
choses importantes bien
à bientôt à samedi j'espère revoir